okay um i'm doing
uh number four from yesterday so if you
are
um having trouble with it that's
understandable because
unlike the previous questions this
question is not a series
at all it looks kind of like a series
that you've got an indeterminate number
of terms
but there's no i mean what's a series a
series is the sum
of a whole bunch of terms right there
are no
sums here right this is actually there's
multiplication this is a product not a
series okay
so um that might mean it looks a little
different but actually
if you follow this through and have some
faith in the principle it actually comes
out
not too badly okay so let's have a go
firstly i'm going to test it out
and the first legitimate value is just
one okay
so how far am i going to get on this
series
if i just put one in well my first term
will be two
right well sorry left hand side is equal
to
one plus one now as i keep on building
this series
how far am i supposed to go right well
for instance
if um n was say 10 okay
and it was 10. my first value would be
11 and my last value would be
20 right um if n was a hundred my first
value be 101
and my last value would be 200 right
so you have an idea of how far you're
gonna go now if my first term is
two well my n is one what will the last
term be
it will be two times one which is two
right so in fact i've already got to my
last term that's it
that's the whole left-hand side okay
so even though i said before um this
first step is meant to be trivial right
sometimes it can still be tricky because
you're like all right what does it
actually look like and you've got to get
it right
okay so now my right hand side
that's equal to 2 to the power of m so
there's 2 to the 1.
now how many terms am i going to have
here
what are these numbers what what um it's
not a sequence or a series but what
pattern does this progression follow
they're the odd numbers right
one three five seven nine and so on and
so on okay so
what's the first number i'm going to
have it'll be one
how how far do i go well i want to get
up to two n
minus one when n is equal to 1 2 n minus
1 will be 2 minus 1. it'll be
1. so i'm already there i'm at my last
term okay so i'm finished okay so that's
2x1 which is 2.
hooray i was able to prove the first
step okay so
it's true for n
equals one okay let's make the
assumption step
so assume true
that's an e for n equals k so what does
it look like
uh this part's not too hard i'm just
straight substitution right
okay now i'm hoping people got to this
point without too much drama
okay because it's sort of it's very
mechanical honestly it's a bit boring
but boring can mean you know
straightforward so that's good too right
now what do i do to prove
the next part right prove true
for m equals k plus one okay
we've said before many times that all
the work is in this step right
um but it's not just in actually doing
the algebra to make it look
correct but it's also in building this
thing correctly
for k plus one there are lots of little
traps you can fall into right
so for instance where am i going to
start i'm not gonna start at k plus one
usually it's like k k plus one k plus
two i'm actually gonna start at
k plus one plus one right which is
k plus two okay should i finish
yeah try this okay um k plus two k
plus three this is going to keep going
and multiplying by
what's here two times if i substitute it
in
i'll get two times k plus one two k plus
two
minus one two k plus two
minus one that's that
is that okay that's my second last term
my last term
is next okay what's that equal to
be careful here particularly with this
next part
all my odd numbers right 1 by 3 by 5 by
and so on
okay what are my terms over here going
to be
well these are odd numbers so my one
before this
at the end should be two k
plus one right uk plus one
what is the odd number before two k plus
one
two 2k minus 1 right be super careful
it's really easy to put something like
say 2k or 2k minus 2
or something else something even right
which breaks out
it doesn't it won't work your algebra
will not work okay so
if you got that right the rest of it
should fall out okay
and i'm making you late so we'll finish
this in this afternoon